yeah apples go ahead in colorado hey now
howard i do a little snooping because i
like to see everybody's instagram
i saw what ronnie did for stephanie but
in the background
there was a bunch of sugary cereals
tricks
lucky charms and it's only because you
recently talked about beth
enjoying those are those ronnie's are
those stephanie's
you know people are so [ __ ] up with
they watch every little stupid goddamn
thing i eat special k
that's what i eat the almond one and the
strawberry one
she eats she likes all that sweet [ __ ]
she likes tricks she like she
sugar pops all that kind of stuff and i
knew he was gonna say something about
the lucky charms because
beth had brought it up that she eats it
you had brought it up
stephanie's been eating it since i know
her so it's not because beth eats it
it's because she likes it and that's
what she eats okay
no i just want to make sure you weren't
eating that sugary stuff
no i don't eat i don't know i just i
just told you you know i have to tell
you you're a little paranoid apples
wasn't saying that stephanie ate that
stuff because
he was concerned why would he why would
he bring it up
if that wasn't what the deal was come on
you think i'm stupid
okay that's why he brought it up he's
trying to cause some [ __ ]
i don't think it was an attack i think
it was a no it wasn't
it was a night a nice attack it was a
quiet i think you're
you're way out of line on this no i'm
not i'm not out of line
apples you could talk about what goes in
and out of my [ __ ] but you shut the
[ __ ] up about my breakfast cereal
go [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself snap
crackle twist ronnie has a hair trigger
he always he always uh he always has a
theory on stuff
i don't know what's going on dude
come on why would you even why would you
even [ __ ] bring it up then
why would you break it off your
medication dude why would you
bring it up what is the purpose of
bringing it up
if you don't want to cause a little
controversy well he certainly has
power because he he thought by doing
this howard would start
oh well she eats it because howard
beth eats it you know i would do that
that didn't even occur to me stupid dude
i'll go eat my special k
and you can go eat [ __ ]
all right okay thanks guys yeah apples
use your real [ __ ] name apples use
your real [ __ ] name what's wrong
ron look at you what the [ __ ] kind of
i mean nobody is accusing stephanie of
eating lucky charms because
beth does i don't even think he did yes
he did i don't think so i never heard
that you have voices in your head
yeah okay i'm telling you you get you
have a hairline trigger i mean you're
like uh oh my god
now he's laughing what are you laughing
about
i i'm crazy so who cares if stephanie
eats uh
lucky charms why are you why are you
going off like this
i don't either it's no big deal i
couldn't cause anything
ronnie nobody he wears that's why
don't you get it that's why he you're
making that assignment
just because stephanie puts this she has
to take pictures
and put this [ __ ] up on [ __ ]
instagram
i knew somebody was gonna [ __ ] do it
i knew it i just
you could call her and ask i said some
[ __ ]
is gonna call into this [ __ ] show and
probably apples
oh does stephanie eat [ __ ] lucky
charms because beth eats it too
i said that's not what he said why do
you have to put it but he didn't say
that
that was this dialogue in your head no
he said
who is he in the lucky charms right if
he didn't say it directly dude he said
it in a roundabout way
why would he [ __ ] call why would he
[ __ ] call
okay so let's go let's say he was doing
that let's say you're saying hey but hey
ronnie
your girlfriend's trying to be just like
beth and eat lucky charms
who cares why are you getting all the
work that's the big deal
because this is what these people do man
this is what they love to do they love
to [ __ ] rile me up
you got to get out of that basement i'm
not in the basement dude
yes you are i know i'm not i'm not in
the basement basement you're in the no
i'm not
i'm not the [ __ ] face i'm in a
[ __ ] office here
[Music]
what the [ __ ] this is my office this is
where i play with my toy cars
okay office all right thank you